my girlfriend sits like you sit with a
little pretzel twist like this the toe
even around the bottom yeah yeah yeah
you gotta hook it you know what don't
look at her anymore oh come on I don't
like it
I look at [ __ ] the high man have you
seen my girlfriend yeah I know hot no no
no Beyond she's special yeah I I
followed her like 10 years ago when she
was like first starting in like her
career she's gorgeous she's gorgeous
yeah do you know who she is yeah have
you seen her I've seen her yeah I don't
know what she is like she's why do I
have to know she is no no sorry I meant
to say in the in the context of uh my
girlfriend have you seen have you seen
her I've seen photos of it but I don't
know which what she does what's her
backstory it's beautiful Bobby I know
she's one of the biggest freaking
supermodels I can't believe well look it
up I'll look let me know she's out of my
league Bobby I really scored with this
one look at this her last post on her
Instagram is like I mean Bobby okay let
me see I can't even
oh my [ __ ] god no I can't I don't
know yeah I don't understand it either
look look okay here's what I would do
I don't care what you would do about it
why are you telling me
I share what I would do if what yeah
I would kill a village
to go out with her
what kind of villain where in the world
are we population for me 1 000 seat
venue of kids of adults that is so many
people but not not like in America
I would just go to some Tibetan Hill and
just Slaughter you know what I mean and
if she was like you know if she was like
captured yeah right by these oh and the
Republicans in the context of 2 000
people kidnap one girl and if you save
her right right that's what I meant no
children or women right but I would just
all men brutal men two thousand men yeah
I'd probably die but that's how
beautiful she is she's congratulations
thank you yeah I think I could have said
that in a different way right without
murder yeah
murder but she's very pretty so when
you're with her you you think to
yourself oh my God I'm so lucky
immensely yeah that's great man it's
incredible I can't believe it do you
guys live together now or no uh damn
near yeah basically wow that's amazing
how did you meet her
uh we both uh uh I well
[Laughter]
it's it's not lame it's well Okay I uh I
did this uh uh a photography project
I'm a photographer as well and uh it was
called The Originals and I was casting
models and we almost got her to be in
one of the photos and we were at the one
yard line with the contract and it fell
apart
and then
five months later we were both paid to
walk the red carpet for the opening of
the Hard Rock in New York City and her
agent still had my contact she saw that
I was there she's like yo I'm here with
Nina and in my head truthfully I didn't
give a [ __ ] because like they they
bailed they bailed on me they blew me
off early like I had I had the nagdoll
locked in to do a [ __ ] photo for my
99 Originals project it was a big deal
so I was like all right like whatever
like I don't care but then Nina took the
agent's phone she texted me she was like
I have a broken back I'm 30 you're gonna
have to come upstairs because I was in
the basement and I was like all right
whatever then you went up there dude
just fireworks immediately like I don't
know it's like I couldn't I couldn't
believe like I knew pretty much right
away like
I'm gonna be with this girl for a long
time oh my god oh wow let me readjust my
dick real quick
yeah the villages no it's fantastic I
can talk about her all day yeah yeah
change the subject Bob it's your pocket
yeah no I do you know we're doing great
man I just wanna I just want to give
good media dude I have some good [ __ ]
he's gonna you got a problem can I see
this you gotta prompt me Bob from since
you've been here to now it's all gold
it's been great media we love you here
thanks dude I want to say this I told
didn't I tell you when and I don't give
a [ __ ] what people say okay after I left
your [ __ ] thing I literally my whole
attitude towards you change I didn't
know who